Amy Schumer is stepping in it to defend
a bachelor contestant I know you can't
control how complicated you are I wish I
assume that's something you fight yeah
it's been years after host Chris
Harrison called a Jubilee sharp
complicated something she actually
called herself first on Monday nights at
whim until all special Amy took to
Twitter to defend the reality star
posting there is nothing wrong with
complicated women Chris Harrison women
it shouldn't try to be less complicated
so as to hopefully attract a man come on
bro Amy continued it she is smart and
strong in a sergeant in the military
she lost her entire family and you say
she must fight off being complicated
tima Jubilee for life Jubilee didn't
think Amy in particular but did tweet
out of thanks to all her supporters
after the show
et was with the 25 year old at the
taping it was an emotional day coming
out here I felt like I had a lot to
answer to and I knew it was good you
know I knew I was gonna be put on the
spot and there's gonna be people coming
from me so um I did what I know you know
best and that's to be honest and open